[Musique]
des muscles des épreuves des sportifs
qui vont au bout de même bienvenue au
French throwdon 2023 la plus grande
compétition de CrossFit en France un
rendez-vous organisé pour la troisième
fois consécutive au Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines l'événement monte
en cuisson sur la courbe est croissante
en terme de public de jauge et
d'athlètes cette année c'est plus de 830
athlètes internationaux qui se sont
réunis à 50 ans en Yvelines c'est une
vraie communauté qui s'implante d'année
en année au coeur du territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc c'est un
véritable état d'esprit que nous on
cautionne qu'on aimerait encourager et
développer au fil des ans une communauté
qu'il faut accueillir dans les
meilleures conditions ici tout est pensé
pour plaire au 9000 visiteurs présents
sur les trois jours à côté des arènes
sportives un village a été installé pour
le rendez-vous on retrouve des dizaines
de stands et notamment des boutiques de
vêtements spécialisés dans le CrossFit
et les CrossFitters en profitent pour
s'équiper pour la compétition
après toutes les brassières ils savent
les marques savent très bien nous faire
craquer sur des modèles différents ce
qui nous les faut tous le CrossFit un
mode de vie quelques mètres plus longs
retrouve même de la nourriture aux
protéines pour les participants une idée
lancée l'année dernière par cette
entrepreneur francilien c'est un produit
que j'ai pas mal présenté dans le monde
du Crossfit et qui plaît énormément dans
le monde de crossier donc voilà donc
c'était la raison pour laquelle je suis
là pour que les gens ils se fasse
plaisir qu'ils puissent manger et en
même temps que ça réponde à leurs
besoins tant que sportifs des
pâtisseries qui permettront peut-être
aux athlètes de performer dans l'arène
ici les 800 sportifs enchaînent les
épreuves de force tout au long de la
journée sous la chaleur le but est
d'être le plus régulier possible pour
marquer des points
pour pas faire de contre-performance
et bah forcément il y a des épreuves qui
sont durs à mais en même temps on est là
pour ça quoi je pense qu'il faut être
complet partout parce que le CrossFit
c'est un mélange de gym de cardio et de
force et quand tu es complet que tu as
ces trois qualités c'est le mieux les
champions les catégories élites ont
remporté les sommes allant jusqu'à 15000
euros l'événement ne devrait pas revenir
l'année prochaine pour une quatrième
édition dans les Yvelines à cause des
Jeux olympiques de 2024 mais les
organisateurs prévoient déjà un retour
sur site après les JO